[Music]
it's tying for et social study your
quick look at what the stars are posting
online Paris Jackson is proving herself
as a force in fashion Michael Jackson's
daughter revealed on Instagram that
she's officially signed with modeling
agency IMG also making a reveal on
Instagram Bristol Palin I'm feeling
blessed the 26 year old shared the
exciting news that her next child will
be a baby girl meanwhile Katy Perry
revealed a major hair transformation
buzz sides and a choppy top we're not
sure if the new look was motivated by
her recent split from Orlando Bloom but
we do know things are amicable she
tweeted you can still be friends and
love your former partners no one's a
victim or a villain and how about this
TBT from lys Witherspoon the actress
back in 1996 when she first got started
she wrote in the caption quote I love
being an actor feeling very grateful for
my amazing job so excited and check out
these tweets from Abigail Breslin the
actress says she suffered a panic attack
while performing on stage
[Music]
you